صباح الخير يا سوزان وشكرًا لاستضافتي ،
تعرف أنه كان أسبوعًا كبيرًا هنا
في ديترويت ، نتحدث عن رئيس Ford
f-150 بايدن كان في المدينة يوم
الثلاثاء كان لديه فرصة لاختبار قيادتها
وما يحدث حقًا مع Ford
شركة السيارات في الوقت الحالي مع
إطلاق هذا في ليلة الأربعاء ، هناك الكثير
من الإثارة حول الكهرباء في
صناعة السيارات في الوقت الحالي
وتقول شركة فورد للسيارات إن هذا سيكون
أكثر f-150 اكتمالاً حتى الآن
يطلقون عليه اسم البرق  السعر
هو ما يتحدث عنه الجميع ، إنه
أقل من 40
ألفًا ، سيكون كل شيء مكهربًا بمحرك في
المقدمة ومحرك في الخلف سيكون
بقوة 563 حصانًا و 775 رطلاً قدمًا من
عزم الدوران على محرك المدى الممتد 300 ميل
سيقدم لك
أيضًا بطارية كهربائية ستبلغ
مداها 230 ميلًا أيضًا ، لكن هذا حقًا
ما أردت أن أعرضه لك هنا ، كل ذلك تحت
الجزء الأمامي بالطبع ليس لديك محرك غاز
سوزان ، لذا احزر ما الذي
يسمونه  انها و  ront لذلك لديك
القدرة على حزم حقائبك من
الداخل ، يمكنك الباب الخلفي مع هذا
بالإضافة إلى أنها حصلت على طاقة كهربائية
هنا ، لذلك من الرائع حقًا أن
تستخدم شركة Ford Motor الجزء الأمامي من هذه
السيارة من وجهة نظر
السعة للتخزين الآن  كل شيء يتعلق
بالكهرباء ، هذا هو المكان الذي
ستقوم بشحنه فيه هنا ،
وستتمكن من شحن هذه السيارة طوال الليل
في منزلك إذا كان لديك شاحن سريع
أيضًا ، فسيتم شحنه بشكل أسرع
بالطبع.  سأقوم
بتوصيله هناك بالنسبة لي ، الأمر كله يتعلق بالفخامة ،
فأنا أحب التصميم الداخلي لهذه السيارة
بالإضافة إلى أنها تحتوي على شاشة تعمل باللمس مقاس 15 بوصة ونصف
في الداخل ، وهي
نفس الشاشة التي تم دمجها في
Ford mustang mach e ول  في المرة الأولى التي
تدمج فيها شركة Ford Motor
شيئًا يسمى Blue Cruise ، وهذا
هو المستوى الثاني للقيادة الذاتية ،
لذا ستتمكن من الجلوس خلف عجلة القيادة ،
وستكون قادرًا على رفع
يديك عن عجلة القيادة مع هذا و
ستقود السيارة نفسها بينما نشق
طريقنا إلى الجزء الخلفي من هذه السيارة ،
وقد يكون هذا هو سدادة العرض بالنسبة لي
مع إضاءة f-150 ، لديك 9.6
كيلوواط من الطاقة في الباب الخلفي
في سرير هذه السيارة مع 11
خيارًا مختلفًا للطاقة  لذلك في
حالة وقوع كارثة وطنية
أو كارثة طبيعية في
منزلك ، فلديك القدرة على التوصيل
وإزدهار فويلا ، وستكون قادرًا على
تزويد منزلك بالطاقة لمدة تصل إلى ثلاثة أيام ،
وهذه تقنية رائعة جدًا
ستكون أيضًا  قادرًا على تشغيل موقع المعسكر الخاص بك وفي
موقع العمل أيضًا من خلال تلك الجبهة ،
ستكون قادرًا على التخلص منه ، لذلك
هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي تحدث مع شركة فورد للسيارات
الآن رائع حقًا لرؤية
الرئيس بايدن هنا في المدينة يقوم
برحلة و  تكريس بعض الوقت لفورد
شركة السيارات وكهربة
هذه السيارة ، لكن بالنسبة لي ، يتعلق الأمر كله
بهذا السعر الذي يبدأ من أقل من 40000
دون مراعاة
الحوافز الضريبية المختلفة على مستوى الولاية
والمستوى الفيدرالي.
مع شركة فورد للسيارات الآن نعود
إليك في أتلانتا سوزان
لك